luca welcome back hey yes
it's great to be back here so um how
does it feel to be back
it feels a bit like when i go back to
italy
and everything is
good and the people are great espresso
is better yes this press is good
but it takes a bit complicated of course
yeah yeah so
yes we we do we do complexity here yes
right yeah
yeah know each other for uh
the longest time right you were you are
undergraduate when i first met you in
italy yeah i was on sabbatical i was in
sabbath i spent a sabbatical in rome
and there you were i was really amazed
to meet you to to live with
i have a good eye so yeah i was
i was a senior in college and you knew
my
advisor because i guess was your postdoc
at san diego
the year before and we
i had a really great time doing a
somewhat research oriented
senior thesis and i didn't get any off
the
real job after i graduated so then i
started doing grad school
great and that seemed to worked out
pretty well
at some point you started working at ibm
yeah pilu christensen my advisor
he also knew madhu sudan was at ibm at
that point
and in my second year of grad school as
was pretty common for students in my
program i was looking for
somewhere to go and spend a period
abroad so i wrote to
madhu to say that i would you like like
to come and visit
uh ibm and the italian government would
pay for the visit and uh mother was
happy this was off season so not in the
summer but in the fall when they don't
have a lot of students going around
i guess mother was happy to have someone
new and
and so i went and very luckily
just a few weeks before going
i was doing this paper on pcp and the
hardness of approximation let me hit the
lot and other gold rack and madhu i just
put online it was a 120 page film
and it was the first time that a lot of
those new ideas on
how to go beyond the original pcp
construction get stronger results were
written down with all the details and
i've been
thinking about one section where they
show how you do reductions from pcp to
optimization problems with gadgets and
they had a very abstract way of thinking
about that and i was thinking
that it should be possible to search for
an optimal gadget
automatically so this is where this idea
came from okay right yeah
it originated in italy okay so i
um so i flew to new york with italia
and they lost my bags without
and then i had to get a car to get to
the ibm lab which was
bit outside of new york city but i was
not 25 so i couldn't get a car
it's on my first day there with no
clothes and no house and no
car i i see like this idea
nothing else to do i told maduro and
he immediately got it and then the
following day
he basically re-explained the idea to me
but uh
much much better and then we talked to
greg sorking and david williamson that
showed how
could it be extended to other problems
and so in a few days we had a
pretty nice piece of work great yeah you
kept working with
madhu after that or not we said in touch
just before i left we were starting to
work on
a classification of constraint
satisfaction problems
which is something that we um yes yes of
course yes
so then i finished well then i ran out
of my
graduate fellowship which the way it was
working italy at that point or
not working was that the fellowship
would run out one year before you would
actually graduate
or sort of the time it took to get
together the graduation
bureaucracy took a year after so i spent
that gap year in
geneva yes yes and i started working on
surroundings and
extractors that was that was also also
very lucky okay right yes
so finally i got officially my phd and i
was going to
spend a year again in new york at ibm
working with madhu but at that point
maduro got offered to
of course so he told me
would you like to come to mit instead
and i said well i would very much like
to come to mit instead
and so uh and then
then you want to you went to columbia
after that year
yeah i i was originally thinking that
maybe after that year abroad i would uh
go back to italy but didier at mit was
was life-changing there were a lot of
great people there other goldrick was
around sabbatical
big impact on me and the students there
they were
meet sahai was there danny lewin
uh adam clions uh gunny dodis talmud
it was a analysis it was a it was a
great group and
in the in the spring semester we did
this reading group
to try to understand the work of abby
witherson and russell impalazzo that
just come out
where they were showing that p equals
ppp and their plausible assumptions
and we actually spent like three months
on that because the table was building
up on
five or six previous papers from the
past 10 years we decided we would really
like to
understand the whole sequence we know
particular goal in mind because it
seemed that the
work of russell and ravi was the final
word on the matter
and he said that reading group led to
a lot of new work so adam cliven said
this idea of applying the same stuff
non-deterministically so independently
with either
will quebec he proved that graph
non-isomorphism is in np under proxy
assumptions
and then i did this work on
extraterrestrial generators
that um it still seems to be the best
thing
yes would be the judge
had some improvement on that that umergo
um reingold and renras also
independently so they started working
together
was that right okay yeah so omar and
salin started working together because
of that
iran was also in that group
uh i think i told avi about the result
and then avi it will run
and then ask for the paper and then
immediately see this improvement that's
a little certain
and that was the beginning of umar and
salim working together that like
so many other things yes right yeah so
yeah
this was this had so much impact that uh
even we at berkeley heard about it and
decided to hire you yeah
and the point i pretty much never been
to california
and i was enjoying life in new york uh
quite a bit
but everybody uh was telling me that
they
wouldn't speak to me again if i didn't
accept the berkeley offered
really okay i thought it was only us who
told you
yes you for sure but actually everybody
else was very
adamant that i had amazing that's good
to know
um great so and
that's how we became colleagues i
what i remember most fondly
is is your uh
let's call it intellectual leadership so
we know that that that
whenever there was something interesting
you
took the chalk and and you took a marker
and then started explaining it
for us at theory lunch you know so so i
learned so many things from you
it was here that you started your blog
am i right yeah this was in
2006 i it was the first year that andy
yao
had started his institute at university
in
beijing and one of my student hote was
spending a whole year there
he was one of three american students
that were there two from berkeley one
from
my team so it was spring break of 2006
it was in the middle of this this year
and i went to spend a week
like giving a couple of talks to the
students there in beijing and
talking to them and also seeing china
for the for the first time
so this was before at least i had
facebook
and uh i it was not before facebook but
it was before your facebook
before i did yes i'm a late adopter
so uh i wanted some place where i could
uh send friends pictures and stories
about what was going on
so much to say yes right yeah so i
started this blog and
i sent it in to a couple of people but
then by the end of the week lots of
people were
reading it so when i came back i thought
maybe i'll keep it running for a few
more weeks and write about some
technical stuff and then eight years
later
it's still still going i was i was a
great fan i hope i hope to
to keep reading it here how did you
combinatorics
yeah there was a it was a time that it
seemed that
well there was this work of being green
and
territory where they proved that the
primes have arbitrary longer with my
productions
and there was a notion of
pseudorandomness in the paper
of showing that someone they already
knew
that then sets of integers have
arbitrary long arithmetic progressions
and then you know that uh
set the integers that in some technical
sense are almost prime
are pseudo-random in a very strong sense
and
the primes were dense inside these
almost primes
and so then they had this intuition that
because i say
if dense sets of integers have this
property
sets that are dense in a surah such it
also have this property
right so they make it they made it work
okay
and what i thought would be really
interesting was to see if there was a
way to understand what they were doing
in the way we think about surroundings
randomness
which there was and that led to a few
interesting pieces of work
and what came next you
worked on you worked more on
approximability in pcp you worked on
the unique games yeah in complexity
theory
the two areas that i keep going back to
are hardness approximation and
approximation algorithms and the
surroundings and the outreach case
complexity
and there was that point that it seemed
that these ideas in additive
combinatorics had some connection i
wanted to
explore and what i worked on next was
motivated by the fact that it seemed
that
random works in graphs and expanded
graphs and
properties of expanders and so on seemed
to
also come up a lot both in complexity
theory
in various areas of complexity theory so
that i would spend maybe a few months
learning about spectral graphics from
the beginning
and have those techniques a little bit
more clear in my mind
but that was five years ago and i'm
still uh
yes working on it we have found that
there is so much
there's so many interesting open
questions and uh
it's so connected to new work on
approximation algorithms so
even extra algorithms like they work on
max flow using electrical networks yes
that's right yes yes
and uh so much that
you are going to be having this semester
program uh starting in a few days yeah
next week or in a couple of weeks we're
going to have a program on speedograph
theory where
all the people we hoped would come came
and it promises to be really exciting
they really
it's got it's occurring at the right
time that
there is already other things that
people have been
developing and it's a good place to
share them but it also seems
uh that there is a tipping point that
something much bigger is going to happen
and maybe the institute we want to be
the the locus
the place for tipping points yes i mean
that that's what the simon's institute
as you know is for yes right
how are you looking uh at your at your
at your role in this i'm at the
institute
well you know when i um when i
interviewed uh
here at berkeley it was a bit different
from the way interviews usually go
because then people like everybody's
trying to tell you about
what the place is like and what your
work is going to be like
in this place but when i interviewed
everybody was asking me so
you're definitely going to be here
senior scientist
and i'm still not so sure but i
i think that really ever since the
experience let me tell you two years
later
i have no idea well like um
like ever since the experience at mit of
that reading group where
we were just interested in one paper and
all kind of things came out of
i really been interested in uh exploring
like new things i don't know much about
but it seems serendipity
yes yes this is uh yeah i love that this
is this is
uh this sounds like a great plan yeah so
sims here i can do that
um as a job
and very intensely and then you know yes
try to connect to people that might be
good organizers for new programs